ai speed humans that go generate text  and even art are ais of today already  smarter than you the short answer is no  while you are a general intelligence  capable of making analogies and quickly  adapting to new situations currently  eyes are highly specialized but have  trouble with mundane situations even  worse they solve problems in unrobust  ways imagine an ai with the goal of  telling the exact time of the mailman's  daily arrival the ai learns his behavior  by observing him for two weeks when  finally ready to make predictions it  notifies you that the mailman has  arrived but you see no mailman only miss  coffee been playing outside why did the  ai make this mistake  because in the two weeks of training the  appearance of the mailman was correlated  with miss coffeebean's appearance such  mistakes are characteristic for today's  ais that are overly complicated  correlation detectors think about this  the next time you see an ai headline